my oh my Steve Harvey throws major shade
and Kelly Clarkson and considers pulling
his hit talk show Steve was upset about
the love NBC is giving Kelly and he is
not afraid to let everybody know it are
you staying with NBC Universal is that
deal going forward I thought I was until
they made an announcement that they
wanted to all give Kelly Clarkson the
owned-and-operated NBC networks
that's my slot Steve Harvey says he felt
snubbed by NBC and even took a jab at
the show that's replacing him who's not
selling like they thought and you look
at the numbers on my show as number four
in daytime television is holding right
there but the daytime shake-up is less
about ratings and more about ownership
NBC only has a distribution deal with
Steve but the network will produce
Kelly's show Clarkson's coaching job on
the voice is just part of a larger
talent deal with NBC I'm an Austin Lake
life coach cheerleader like yeah you can
do it and the network made her show
happened fast here's a timeline hey
what's up y'all welcome to the Kelly
show in April of last year Kelly did a
mock show on Ellen and August she shot a
pilot episode we're told the set was
built to resemble the inside of a barn I
hope people like it the following month
September NBC announced that Kelly
Clarkson show would premiere this fall I
really want to be good at it because I
love the opportunities that it presents
like for me to be able to do it's pretty
powerful and I'm pretty excited about it
but don't count Steve Harvey out the
talk show host says he's considering
moving his show to a streaming platform
like YouTube or Facebook I got a look at
I gotta be smart you know I gotta think
about it because that's where it's
headed
they're both great personalities room
for everybody okay
[Music]